if you are a fan of YouTube you probably
know who these guys are two brothers who
are an internet sensation internet
sensation it says so right there
internet sensation everyone on YouTube
watches us there's no one who doesn't
obviously I'm enough of an internet
sensation that I've just taped several
pieces of boob construction paper behind
me so I could do blue screen stuff and
generally should probably say that I'm
not a very big fan of the local news I
kind of feel like it would be cool for
people wants this video on YouTube then
they did on television just as you know
a way to prove that we are better than
they are but I gotta say I kind of like
this local news report because it's
about me actually they'll ever think
about it's kind of mostly old John hmm
nonetheless though I did enjoy this
report there are several factual
inconsistencies that I would like to
comment on a couple of other things that
aren't factual inconsistencies that I
would also like to comment on and so I
hope you'll enjoy this broadcast from
Chicago's local news and Susan Carlson
doing great rep voltage and the little
bit of commentary from me over the job
and a cbs2 Susan Carlson reports and
nerds are rejoicing Orlando natives John
and Hank green agreed to stop texting
each other last year texting makes it
sound like we agreed to stop text
messaging each other last year which is
not the case at all textual
communication is different from texting
Susan cop and instead communicate only
through video blog or vlog I'm on and
dad's house the last residents in the
United States of America with dial-up
inter oh my god Tonya used to talk so
slow to their surprise the public
communication resulted in a youtube
sensation to date thirteen point five
million viewer thirteen point not nine
million viewers what was I doing no
writers have logged on to watch their
videos which have an underlying message
I think that we're trying to bring
people who feel like they're on the
outside internet celebrity internet
celebrity I
hilarious and into a place where they
feel like they're on the inside
John was already a successful author
with a teen set but his fame skyrocketed
through the internet having previously
lived in Chicago he was back in one of
his old stomping grounds today in
Washington library promoting his books
the enthusiastic crowd included about
400 young adults some of whom waited
over two hours to meet the brothers
mrs. pink hair and dftba trucker cap I
don't remember your name and I'm sorry
for that but you went today's
nonexistent nerdfighter Prize because
you are awesome their fans referred to
as nerdfighters now Susan I am glad that
you summoned up the courage to actually
speak the word nerdfighters but really
the Velociraptor air quotes were not
necessary nerdfighters nerdfighters
nerdfighter arn't obsessed with Britney
Spears or Justin Timberlake just to be
clear that is not entirely true I kind
of have a JT thing instead they've
latched on to someone they say they can
relate to having somebody that has so
much in common with me like valuing
breeding and education and thinking it's
cool Detroiters very real and they
understand people as a parent the
message that they're sending is a real
strong one about young people in today's
American growing up as individuals
parental nerdfighters after a year of
video messages only the brothers are
communicating in other ways again but
they say the vlogs will continue we'll
do it for as long as people will watch
it I think John you and I didn't discuss
that little bit before you announced it
to the world but you know okay Susan
Carlson CBS 2 News this is Hank green
reporting for wowt f news nerdfighteria